au mois de mai en classe verte on
s'éclate et dans le cantal on appris
plein de trucs chouettes sur la nature
et le monde rural
on a parlé de pollution du climat qui
s'en va de travers on a pris des
résolutions va peindre le monde envers
marcel bidot à 73 ans cet ancien chargé
d'insertion à la fin est devenu slameur
marcel dont l'anagramme et clamer
déclamé en marchant il répète ses textes
et les fit vivre en même temps l'auteur
de nouvelles désormais calé son flot
dans le rythme du slam et de ses
exigences littéraire là je découvrais
mois que en donnant des contraintes des
contraintes de pied j'écris beaucoup en
auto décima huit pieds et puis des
contraintes de rim et bien j'allais
avoir des nouvelles idées qui allait
sortir auquel j'avais pas pensé et qui
souvent mal être un peu plus riches
texte un prétexte il se fait connaître
pour son travail 6 et son âge interpelle
aussi dans le monde des slameurs son
inspiration vient du regard qu'il porte
sur le quotidien et tous les sujets peut
déclencher en lui un besoin d'écrire et
de réciter ils travaillent souvent avec
des enfants pour transmettre sa passion
des rythmes et des mots de spectacle en
spectacle ils façonnent sa réputation au
gré des rencontres
oui enfin je vais dire qu'il ya des gens
qui estiment en temps pour la première
fois et qui nous dit qu'ils n'ont jamais
ce qu'ils ne connaissent pas qui nous
ont parlé à ma copine aller à la
bibliothèque ne telle commune ça va leur
plaire à parler à telle association
nous on un festival dans là où je vais
en vacances je leur en parler voilà
comment ça se fait elle matin des
rideaux stalactites recouvrait en partie
les carreaux du survitrage insolite
recyclage gratuit
bientôt il sera sur la scène de terres
du son ben c'est le goût d'eau
intarissable infatigable aiment cette
musique des mots et de la nature
les mots sont ces notes son instrument
la voix les accrochages dans le djebel
les retransmissions l'olympiade brassens
piaf montand brrr